-Welcome to the show.
-Great to be here.
-I think most people
who know you
know you from election night
You are a superstar
on election night.
You work the map.
You are often very frazzled.
And we actually cut together
a highlight reel.
This is from a special election.
in Pennsylvania, 2018.
Let's take a look.
-Kasie, and I have to stop you
Steve Kornacki has a piece o
paper in his mouth.
Steve, I keep wondering
if you are
looking for my attention.
Do you -- Okay. Pen, pen.
Okay.
-Yes, I -- We're gonna just --
Let's go to math class.
-You've probably got to get --
Let's say you've got to
get 1,625.
-1,625.
-It's early morning.
You're awake with me.
How exciting is this?
We've got an election
coming down to absentees
in Washington County,
Pennsylvania.
We all get to watch it together!
-Very enthusiastic.
It's a joy to watch.
-Thank you.
-And, of course,
couldn't help notice,
one of the things that was
making that night
particularly hard -- you had
a cast on one of your hands.
Was that --
That was a recent injury, yes?
-The day before that --
or two days before that --
I had gone over
the handlebars on a bike.
So that was --
I had a broken hand.
And I had to go to surgery about
10:00 a.m. the morning
after that election.
So, we were up until 5:00 a.m.
waiting for the final vote
to come in.
I had no sleep
and then I went to surgery
as soon as I got out of there.
-Well, you did a fantastic job
Way to play through the injury
-Thank you.
-So, I'm really enjoying
your impeachment podcast.
You both sort of fill
everybody in on --
You know, 'cause, again, there's
just, like, a new name,
a new face every day.
You give us context as to
who these people are.
You also give
historical context.
How is this comparing
right now to the
Clinton impeachment
and the Nixon impeachment?
-Yeah, I mean, just if you loo
at the politics of it,
I think there's a stronger
comparison to
the Clinton impeachment 20 years
ago than to the Nixon one.
And I say that because
of polarization.
It's that word we use
all the time, right?
The party is being so dug in
When you look back at Watergate,
the Nixon impeachment drive,
what you saw was --
every new development,
every new revelation,
public opinion moved with it
So, you know, support for
impeachment started very low
It started very low
in both parties in 1973.
By the summer of '74,
when Nixon resigned,
it was overwhelming support,
about 2/3 majority
in the polling.
Even among Republicans, ther
was support for impeachment.
So, you look at that
and you compare it to
today, and, still, you know,
Democrats are almost
universally in favor of it
Republicans are almost
universally opposed.
You just see polarization righ
now in the numbers on this
-And, so, now, of course,
starting tomorrow,
we're going to see the
first of our public hearings
Democrats --
I should start by saying,
Republicans have been
clamoring for this
to be brought into the public.
Democrats have allowed it to b
brought into the public.
The idea of being that
maybe this will
tip the scales more.
Yet, with this polarizatio
you're talking about,
it strikes me as very unlikely
there will ever be --
should this go to the Senate
that there will ever be enough
Republican senators
willing to switch sides
to impeach the president.
Is that your thinking as of now?
-I mean,
politicians follow the polls
One of the reasons we're alway
putting the polls up there
is because they guide
the actions of politicians
And if you're a Republican
politician right now
and you're trying to make sens
of what's going on
in your own party --
Remember, if you lose a primary,
you lose your job.
And I think they see their party
almost universally, as I said,
behind Trump, almost universally
against impeachment.
You think back to the
2016 campaign.
Donald Trump won that
nomination in 2016,
basically going around
all of these
Republican elected officials
He didn't have a single
endorsement from a Republica
in Congress until he won the
New Hampshire primary,
and I think that delivered
a very powerful
psychological message, really,
to Republican members of
Congress that,
"Wow," they would say.
"Our voters, our people,
the people who elect me,
are with him.
I'd better be, too."
-There -- Isn't there also
an argument --
Let's say it never is
going to lead to him
getting removed from office,
but bringing these public,
you will then have to
force politicians
to choose a side and be on
the record for history
as where they landed, especially
as more and more comes out
And the things that
they said a month ago --
"Look, if it was this,
I'd feel differently."
And then this happens,
and they're like,
"No, and now
it's got to be that."
And that happens, and
they're, like,
"Guys, I don't know
what to tell you."
I mean, isn't there
some value in that?
-Well, yeah.
I think there is a political
angle on it, too,
just in terms of, sure,
there's a lot of Republicans -
Lindsey Graham,
I think you might be
referring to right there.
-Sure.
-Lindsey Graham's got to run
for re-election next year.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-His big challenge in
South Carolina is
the Republican primary.
But there are other
Republican Senators --
Susan Collins in Maine.
Maine's a blue state, right?
Maine's a state that went
for Hillary Clinton.
Cory Gardner in Colorado -
blue state.
They've got to balance
the demands
of the Republican primary with
"Hey, I got to win a
general election, too,
and that could be close."
And I think those are
the ones --
if this does get to the Senate
if this does become a trial,
they've got the trickiest
political calculation to make,
because, on the one hand,
they don't want to
anger that Republican base
get a primary challenge.
On the other hand, they coul
anger general-election voter
who don't like Trump.